bonjour à toutes et à tous ravi de vous
voir aussi nombreux pour assister à
cette conférence
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter
quelque chose d'assez particulier où
vous allez pouvoir participer en fait à
une expérience je vais vous demander de
rêver de rêver à un futur qui est assez
proche mais un futur qui va s'avérer
très très beau et qui sera le meilleur
je l'espère
donc pour faire une belle coupure avec
ce que vous aviez tout à l'heure je vous
proposais de vous lever tous on sent
l'entrain merci merci de garder un petit
peu le silence parce que ceux en fait
cet instant on va vous permettre de vous
recentrer vous recentrez de faire un peu
le vide avec ce qui se passe autour de
vous maintenant ce qui va se passer ce
sera surtout en vous dans votre tête
dans votre coeur donc j'espère que vous
allez pouvoir rêver avec moi et qu'on
puisse imaginer ce futur alors je vous
propose tout d'abord de prendre une
belle inspiration en oubliant tout est
expiré
parce que je suis aussi stressé du coup
ça me fait du bien
maintenant que ce que vous avez pu vous
recentrer et faire un peu le vide dans
votre tête vous pouvez vous rasseoir
avec l'esprit positif
merci pour votre participation
partons maintenant dans ce rêve imaginé
nous sommes en 2035 il ya cinq ans la
suisse achevé sa transition écologique
c'est assez incroyable à penser mais
mais oui elle a réussi nous avons réussi
à devenir quasiment zéro carbone donc on
est mais carrément plus plus de gaz à
effet de serre on produit quasiment plus
de déchets on a aussi diminué
drastiquement notre consommation qui
rappelons le en 2019 était trois fois
trop grande par rapport à ce que ce que
la terre pouvait nous produire en un an
bref tout c'est tous ces changements
toutes ces modifications ont permis à la
suisse de vignes de devenir exemplaire
exemplaire sur le plan écologique grâce
à toutes les forces créatrices donc de
toutes les personnes qui étaient là
disponibles pour donner leur énergie
dans cette transition écologique nous
avons réussi aujourd'hui nous vivons
paisiblement paisiblement tous ensemble
nous peur pour l'avenir nos peurs pour
cet avenir qu'on présentait comme assez
difficile avec notamment des pertes
assez importante parmi les effectifs
humains mais aussi dans toute la
biodiversité avec des manques d'eau
possible cet avenir est désormais chose
choses passées on n'y pense même plus
puisqu'on a réussi à changer cela en dix
ans à peine
et toutes ces peurs se sont finalement
transformées en sentiments de joie
d'amitié ou d'amour la transition
écologique était vraiment bénéfique pour
toutes et tous toutes et tous
c'est pour toute la planète on a réussi
à envisager un futur dans lequel on ne
vit plus pour nous mêmes on vit plus
pour nous mêmes et pour la planète
ça change un petit peu de ce qu'on pense
et en 2019 ou ont pensé à simplement
parfois devenir riche gagner de l'argent
juste pour un hamas et finalement se
retrouver à la fin de notre vie et dire
m'a finalement qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
que j'ai fait de bien sur cette terre
aujourd'hui on ne se pose même plus
cette question on se sent bien avec
notre vie on a pour tous pour but
d'embellir notre vie d'embellir notre
vie mais aussi celle des autres donc
c'est un peu tous c'est un peu tout ce
qu'on a ce qu'on se souhaite vivre tous
en communion est heureux
les mauvaises expériences du passé tels
que les guerres les conflits ou les
tensions en pratiquement disparu on
enseigne aujourd'hui une branche assez
peu connue en 2019 c'était la
communication non violente
c'est un outil assez incroyable il
permet de d'apaiser les peuples
d'apaiser nos esprits se reconnecter à
nos réels besoins à ce qu'on a
réel ce qui nous est réellement
nécessaire on a aussi appris à mieux
comprendre nos émotions à les aborder et
ne plus avoir peur de de s'exprimer et
de voir la vie belle
désormais c'est la paix et l'union qui
règne nous vivons en harmonie
non seulement entre humains entre
différents peuples mais aussi nous
vivons en harmonie avec notre écosystème
toute cette nature qui nous entoure mes
animaux les plantes des arbres tout cela
est finalement avec nous et nous vivons
avec et grâce à cela nous arrivons à
produire ce qui nous est nécessaire
le monde est beau l'humain est beau
aujourd'hui excusez mon petit billet
petit bug mais finalement c'était pour
pour le silence pour exprimer un silence
qui diffère finalement de de notre vie
précédente où c'était le vacarme qui
régnait le vacarme des industries le
vacarme des moteurs des camions ou des
voitures
aujourd'hui ce sont de douces mélodies
qu'on entend des mélodies qui
s'entendent dans les champs les vastes
prairies fleuries avec les criquets qui
chante les oiseaux on a aussi sur les
toits au loin en avançant un petit peu
on peut se rendre compte que et des
abricots qui sèche sur les toits les
abricots du valais qu'on connaît tous ce
qu'on a mis à sécher pour profiter de de
ce soleil qui est riche en valais ils
répondent une bonne odeur une odeur très
douce très agréable et tout cela ont
beau finalement le peuvent et donne
envie de vivre et d'être plus heureux
plus loin vous fait de pas vous tombez
sur un pommier un pommier rempli de
fruits très juteux vous en payez vinh
vous l'a croquée et là vous sentez la
différence la différence en ce qu'ils
avaient en 2019 avec des fruits au goût
insipide
finalement on l'avait oublié ce bon goût
de la la pomme la vraie pomme on n'ose
d'ailleurs l'accueillir et la manger
sont sans se poser de questions
finalement puisque
en prenant de nouvelles variétés qui est
fait et les anciennes et bien on a
réussi à ne plus utiliser de pesticides
les pesticides qui était mauvais pour
l'environnement mais pour nous aussi
surtout nous avons donc repris goût
repris goût à cette nature accessible
directement plus loin vous voyez vos
amis que vous appelle vos amis qu'on
appelait autrement en 2019
c'était vos collègues aujourd'hui on a
tellement une relation proche avec nos
collègues que ce sont nos amis on arrive
à construire un monde un monde un monde
beau voulait rejoignez en enfourchant un
vélo et là vous commencez à cultiver la
terre la terre qui sculptures qui se
cultive en permaculture permaculture qui
est désormais devenu le modèle
d'exception en modèle un peu un peu
nouveau qui qui est utilisé aujourd'hui
par l'agriculture et qui permet de
produire en abondance de la nourriture
sans avoir un impact fort sur
l'environnement aujourd'hui on est aussi
presque tous végétariens
gt rien parce que finalement on s'est
rendu compte de l'absurdité de deux
manches de donner à manger de la
nourriture aux animaux
alors que finalement cette nourriture on
aurait pu la manger nous mêmes et voilà
il ya des peuples sur la planète qui ne
qui n'ont pas accès directement à la
nourriture qu'on donne à manger aux
animaux
du coup on sait on s'est rendu compte de
ça et avec avec ce simple changement
on a réussi non seulement à baisser
énormément les les quantités de gaz émis
mais aussi à pouvoir nourrir l'ensemble
de la planète suffisamment parce qu'il
faut savoir qu'en 2019
un tiers de la nourriture qu'on
produisait ne passait même pas dans
notre assiette
on s'est dit mais comment c'est possible
du coup c'est pour ça qu'on a changé ça
et en 2035
on est fier d'avoir réalisé cette
immense défi
je vais maintenant vous inviter à
contempler une dernière fois ce ce monde
ce monde un peu utopique certes mais ce
monde qui qui donne parfois envie qui me
donne énormément envie en tout cas de
fermer votre votre sac de voyage de
revenir avec tous ces beaux souvenirs et
de garder sérieuse dans notre coeur de
manière à venir en revenir en 2019
en 2019 ou nous sommes face à un immense
défi celui de la transition écologique
la transition écologique a besoin de
tout le monde de tout le monde
avec toutes les petites touches qu'il
peut donner
pierre rabhi appelle cela des colibris
les colibris qui qui oeuvre pour la
transition écologique
donc soyez tous des petits colibri en
gardant votre coeur justement ce rêve
pourrait peut-être accéder à la sphère
réalité finalement votre faim fef ce
rêve réalité
merci
[Applaudissements]